Yes. Probably i going on we go.
One great concern i have 20 years
after the nimbin experiment started.
Is that the ideas and ethics of
the. The nimbin inverted commas.
Workforce. Are certainly the best we have
i think we need. I think we've got lost.
It's it's now 20 years since
the nimbin experiment began.
And i feel more than ever
that the ideas and ethics of
that era were exceptionally fine and we
don't have to apologize for these things
but what concerns me enormously is
that often the energy levels don't match
the ideas and as opposed to this.
We have normal society where
often there's tremendous energy
but it's usually destructive energy and
somehow we have to marry the ideas
and aspirations and wonderful philosophies
of the new age with the energy
and ability and strength of the the old
age. If that's what you like to call it.
I don't know how we do that because
at the moment the the energies
and strengths of conventional
society are destroying the planet
and we have to turn this around somehow.
But sometimes when you see the
lack of motivation amongst.
Local greens and the idea that somehow
the law just work out by itself.
I despair a bit.
But in the long term i think somehow
those ideas will come through
and we will manage to meet them
with the activity levels as well.
We have to be in it for the long
haul. We don't have a choice.
We all have to work as well as
we can and the main way to do
that at the moment is to
keep positivity levels up.
I think this is where the the american comic
friend pete is got an enormous amount
to teach us.
Because she is seems to have dedicated her
life lately to recognizing the despair
levels. In not only greens but a
lot of other people on the planet
and she makes quite obvious.
The fact
that you're not going to be effective in
anything you fight for unless you stay
positive and often that means laughing.
So her mission is in fact
to make people laugh about.
Subjects that i guess you would call.
Gallows humor. They're really.
Terrible prospects death of planet
nuclear war pollution on the grand scale
but she can make us laugh
about it and in that way.
Empower us completely and so some of the.
The mantras
that she's used in her talks i just
find it tremendously powerful for me.
One of them is this is a mantra
that you say after you've been pretty
depressed about a particular issue
and it goes. Oh what a disappointment
and another another mantra of hers
or a slogan is.
The people united will sometimes
win and sometimes lose.
And
when she says there's been a big auditorium
it brings the house down because we've
all been there. We've all for the
issues and lost them and feel
that was the end of the world but she's
teaching us to pick ourselves up
and keep going. It's ok to lose.
It might be the end of the world
but it's not the end
of you for the moment.
When you.
Yes i do think there is quite a significant
burnout level amongst a lot of the old
aquariums. But against
that we have an extremely hopeful sign of
a whole new breed of people have in fact
made an industry out of
keeping people positive
and these people are extremely skilled
and specialized in their outlook
and these people are going to be the ones
that really matter in the end
because they can get us going again
and i think it's fair enough to take a
lot of knock backs the planet is in bad
shape. So it's it's ok to
be depressed about. At it.
We just have to make sure we have a few
little skills to get us back on track.
So we can keep fighting and feel
that there is some reason to keep going
because basically we don't have a choice.
We can't back out where in here we're
stuck and the only thing is to keep going
and the only way to keep
going. Is to stay positive.
So it's a bit of a circle
but if you look at the right way
you can feel it's all worthwhile.
When you look at the beauty of the
place how can you not fight for it.
I always wonder why do people
feel that it's hopeless.
It's obvious that you have to
keep going. And thank you.
And to take.
Young hugh nicholson i came to the
area to throw me a creek in 1974
after. I was a teacher in melbourne
and gradually became more
and more aware of problems of pollution
and environmental degradation
or actual stuff
and although i was getting through to kids
with my teaching i just felt as though
what i really wanted to do was to
try and live a simpler lifestyle
and see where it was possible rather
than just trying to tell people
that it would you could do it.
And so with nan and i set
off looking for land
and after a year of searching
we found a place here.
And tried to virtually drop out.
I guess you'd say supposedly living a
subsistence lifestyle and very simply.
But in fact it's extraordinarily difficult
to do anything with not only difficult
but living a subsistence life
style is incredibly boring.
Because you've got to work
your vegie garden every day
and you've got to make sure that the
birds don't pinch your fruit and
and then there are some things that you
can't produce readily like rice or wheat
or whatever
and you do need some money to buy so you
end up getting caught up in that cycle
and that system anyway.
But we still have a lot of those philosophies
of producing what tucker we can from
our own place
and still living a simpler
lifestyle than most people
but.
We're not bent on pure
self-sufficiency anymore.
It was an end at the time we came
it was what we intended to do
but within a couple of weeks of
arriving at the rainier creek.
We heard of forest commission
plans to log to rainier creek and
when we followed up that
inquiry we found out
that the plans were to log
all the miliband timber
and then to clear fell arrest and burn it
and plant with jiffy pop eucalypts
and only two species because
they are the only trees
that will grow faster than
lantana and so the intention
and what they were doing in the
rest of the local state forest at
that time was now clearing about 500
acres a year and replanting it.
Do you call it. Flooded gum and black
but and since we look out on to.
Tharani creek and the walls
of rainforest and so on here.
The concept of having
that converted from rainforest to eucalypt
plantation full of lantana was just
absolutely beyond comprehension.
So that's why we started
fighting complaining.
I've just happened to be here one day
under here a vehicle up in the forest
and we were at the end of a of a
one way road as far as i was aware
that there was no road beyond us.
And when i walked into
forest to explore and try
and track down the sound i found
that there was an old forest road
coming down the side of the hill
and there was a forestry road again.
Working there cleaning
up the water tables and.
I asked whether they had
any intentions of using
that road for access to tharani creek
and were they planning to logon in their
innocence the the fellows on the work gang
said yes
and i think they've learned a lot since
then they don't tend to be so open with
their answers anymore and.
So having got a yes from then
that they would be in some time we
immediately contacted the office
and melinda which is a local forestry
office and asked what were the intentions
and again because they hadn't confronted
a situation like this before with people
opposing what they were doing
they were open with their answers
and said yes they were intending to clear
fell it burned. And converted to euclid.
And so it went on from there.
You.
Was about five years of ongoing
letters to politicians trying to
develop a public awareness so we were
conducting walks up into the forest with
anybody who wanted to go and and
part of the problem with that was
that some of the forests had been logged
in the past and so it was unlocked
but it was about a two hour walk because
the old logging road was buried in lantana
and i saw stuff
and it made slow walking so about time we
got somebody two hours into the forest
they were ready to turn around to come
out again because they were mostly city
people and their impression
was i don't mean logs
and they didn't actually get to see this
other major portion of it which hadn't
been logged in the past and
was absolutely spectacular
and so we were we were up against
that as a problem. Quite often. That.
People didn't have the stamina to
actually see undisturbed forest
and didn't have the knowledge
to appreciate the effects
that logging it had on the other.
Well as they're walking through.
The absolute highlight of the blockade
for me was the organization of the camp.
I was just so impressed by the ability of.
What i so-called derogatorily called
hippies to coordinate so well.
The camp within the first but the
first the end of the first day
or second day we had water on to the
camp and from then on for the four weeks
or whatever it was of the camp.
There was hot running water for
showers at any time day or night.
There were incredible meals cooked.
We had donations of food from in lismore
shopkeepers would donate stuff and
and people would go out and buy supplies
and bring them in donate them to the camp
and there were there was one group of
people who just decided to be the cooks
and they put on three course meals
every day we just brilliant.
They were better in fact than a lot better
than we were eating back at our house
because we were so involved in
phone calls and media stuff
that there was often not time to prepare
meals it was a really scratch meals where
it up there were dead people dedicated
to just getting a meal together
and then there were firewood.
Gatherers and and so on and so
that was in the camp itself.
And back here at the house we
had people with media skills.
We had one who every day would pull a
final part and connect is wise into it
and send his press releases off
directly through the phone
and there was a duplicating
machine appeared.
God knows where from but it appeared
and it was in the garage just
and every night it was
duplicating off press release
and so on for handouts to the media when
they turned up the next day so it was.
Just. Incredibly well organised
and it all just happened.
Together and i found that fascinating
and interesting the after four weeks
of occupation of the campsite.
There was no rubbish
there were the only sign
that people had been there was
the grass was a bit flattened
and a couple of people had levelled
sloping ground to put a tent
that was there was. All the rubbish had
been buried and all so stuff and yet.
Within a week of the
camp being dismantled.
There were opposing groups who were coming
and having rallies in the area
trying to promote their angle
and invariably we had to spend a day after
each one of these cleaning up their
rubbish in their garbage after which
it was really dramatic contrast
and comparison.
Well. It wasn't a pure victory
i guess it was a victory in
that the logging was stopped.
And it's interesting to talk about the
politics of the actual stopping of the
logging because at one stage the loggers
were intent on filling as many trees as
possible. And so they were just coming in
and dropping trees as fast
they could almost on the run.
They'd fell a tree
and some of these trees were radiocarbon
dated at in excess of a thousand years
and they were really impressive trees
and the figures that we got were
that there were about 600 trees
that was all into running a creek
it was a very minor issue really
and they found out
that if they logged as fast as they could
then they could get 20 trees a day on the
ground and often
that meant falling trees across each other
which in some cases split the trunk so
it was incredibly wasteful but they
were just really going for it anyway.
One friday afternoon
that they had spent a day of doing this
just felling trees as fast as possible.
And then they knocked off and went home
for the weekend and over the weekend.
Somebody and we still don't
know who but somebody went up
and actually cut up the fallen trees into
two meter lengths they just sawed through
them with a chainsaw
and there was a lot of
adverse media from that
and the storming lobby obviously picked
up on it as being the most horrendously
vandal east thing to have done.
But what it meant was that
when they came back next week.
They only filled three trees a day.
Because the trees were so big
that they can only fit part
of a tree on a logging junker
and they could only take
nine trucks out a day
and so it's slowed the whole operation
down they worked on for another week
and they cut another 20 trees.
But if they hadn't been
stymied by the felling
and by the cutting up of the fallen logs
they would have had the job half done in
that week. So it's been it
was interesting how how
that action which got a lot of bad
press was in fact what say the forest
and now of course everybody
who are to run a creek.
What a benchmark decision you know
that was the forerunner of of this world
heritage rainforest which we're all so
proud of.
But it comes from what
we've seen as being it.
And yes.
Ran as a politician was on the side
but he had a very divided cabinet
and so it was a fine balancing act
and he got caught up in in trying to spin
the thing out long enough to get enough
people in cabinet to come on
the side and so in the way
that the logging was not yes we
won but we didn't have an inquiry
and i would never ever recommend anybody
again asking for an inquiry as being
the way out. I'm an issue because we got
involved in an exhausting. Inquiry that.
Went on for for two years i think and.
The forestry people had all their experts
in the sawmill it had their paid it
spurts and we were expected to be there
to put our case if we weren't there
when we were unable to refute
the stuff that they said
but obviously all of it
came out of our pockets and
that win against us too because
the judge said we were in there.
Not for financial gain.
But because we're emotionally involved
and if we're in vocally involved in
obviously our evidence was suspect.
Whereas these guys working for forestry
commission who are being paid to do their
job and if they didn't say the
right things would lose their job
that was ok obviously everything
they said was perfectly true
and correct was a very difficult inquiry.
It was hard during that inquiry
to stay enthusiastic. One.
I'll tell you a classic.
One of our people was giving evidence
on the wildlife use of the forest
and the need for old growth
trees with hollow branches
and he'd gone into quite a long explanation
of the types of animals the possums
and the gliders and the owls
and all the stuff that uses.
Hollow branches in the fact
that a number of these are rare
and endangered animals and
they occur into rainier creek
and after pages of evidence on this.
The judge finally turned to men said.
I can't see the relevance
of this information.
The loggers don't take the hollow
branches. They are left in the forest.
What's the problem. So
the judge could not see
that hollow branches 100 feet
in the ground used by animals
that use the canopy of the forest.
He believe
that the same branches lying on the forest
floor would be just as useful to the
owls and possums so his view was
that just taking out the stems
and leaving the branches was quite ok so
his his understanding of ecological points
was. Non-existent. He was horrified of
the forest he couldn't stand it and.
At one stage we took all the rest of
the inquiry down to a particular pool
in the creek where locals had used it
for picnics for 50 years they've been
visiting this place and he couldn't
get there because he was so old
and decrepit that he couldn't
get off the track and so we.
When we got back up to the cars and
he was asking what we have seen.
And we told him the people reporting
back to him told him what they'd seen
and his response that was were there
any picnic tables chairs barbecues.
The answer was no so he disbelieved all
evidence that anybody might have use
that place for picking it was ridiculous
to assume that people use it.
There weren't barbecues and picnic
tables and it was a lie to suggest
that people use our place.
He couldn't comprehend people
going to the forest for enjoyment
and being prepared to walk.
It was an uphill battle actually.
I think unfortunately i think
that there are still a lot of people who
are city based who would still see feel
the same way. And
that is the battle now for the green
movement is to get through to the people who
don't relate to the natural environment.
That no matter what they think the
natural environment relates to them.
And that they're tied up with it
and that they can't escape it.
And i think for people who live
all their life in the city.
It is possible to believe that.
The problems that are talked about
don't exist. And if in fact you.
Live in a house get in a car
park in a covered car park
and go to work in an office come home.
You don't need to know what move.
There's doing you don't need to
know whether it's clouding raining.
Unless there's a bit of an
inconvenience of the weekends.
You don't need to relate
to the environment.
And that that is the problem you're getting
kids who are growing up in the sea.
You know don't see trees you don't
run on grass and so it's people like
that who find it really hard to
relate to the environment and to see
that problems of pollution will
eventually have an effect on them.
The rubbish that they produce.
Has to go into a landfill somewhere
and landfill sites are running out what do
we do with the rubbish do we in fact do
what they do in america
and take it out to see them barge in
just open the bottom and dump it.
There's a limit to how
many times you can do
that.
You're welcome. On tape. I do.
It's the 6th of december 99.
And we're speaking with david stein.
S p a i n as in portugal.
And introduce yourself and.
Yes but my name's david spain.
I'm age 45 now i came to town
to ball falls in early 1975
at that time.
I'd been living alone in the
countryside north of bathurst
and working in the attorney-general's
department as a legal officer.
Trying to get a fix on what was wrong
with the world and how to set it right.
Why there were such phenomena as.
Wars especially the war in vietnam for which
i am mongst many other of my age group
then ballot of the in.
The increasing pollution which was
becoming obvious 20 years ago.
Guinness of inner city.
These rich poor gap.
Unemployment.
I was part of the post-war baby boom
generation which always grew up with peace
and plenty. Vietnam war was
an enormous culture shock.
I think to all of my generation
that such a horrific occurrence
could embroil us personally.
Being conscripted was an
affront to the spirit
and conscience to fight a wall in which
there was little intellectual belief.
After the war of course
whitlam came to power.
That was a euphoria.
Suddenly the possibility of really
building examples of utopian lifestyle in
australia
and evidencing a low impact low demand
way of life which made big centralized
government unnecessary.
Allowed people to only work a
day or two a week for income
and the rest of the time either.
For some subsistence farming
or building their own homes.
Exploring the finer things of
life music reading meditation.
This whole utopian vista became possible
of implementation or so it seemed.
Then the queries festival
was held in may of 1973.
It was a coming together
of this flower power.
Hope love idealism.
Sense of empathy between people which.
It was the product of.
That post-war generation coming up against
the ugliness of vietnam conflict.
And i'm sure psychedelic drugs had a lot
to do with it quite a unique generation
looking back.
And out of the aquarius festival came
the project of buying a property
and setting up a permanent
sustainable community.
In dwelling those ideals which we
held during the previous decade.
Chairs were sold for a mere
200 dollars intangible falls.
Gradually these were sold to some
people who bought a share and an idea.
Others who came to settle here.
And within two
or three years this entire property hundred
four thousand dollars a been subscribed
to and paid off. The valley.
Spearing in from the south to the nightcap
range with spur lines running down into
the clear valley and
timber along the ridges.
The initial settlers. Varying
and between 40 and 70 or so.
Mostly lived together in the old farmhouse
per cent of the property which was
painted white. It was ironically called
the white house. At the north end.
Was another worker's cottage where a
group of 15 or 20 centered themselves.
Say in this surely the
political motivation
would have been close to communist utopia.
Now the idea was everyone living
and working together. In.
Wholly happy organism.
But within a year
or so there are a lot of tensions
developing in the workers had the bludgers.
The people who went particular
to drugs hated those who were.
Wanted to be smoking or. Magic
mushrooms and so on all the time.
Vegetarians didn't like the meat eaters
for one reason or another. The initial.
Communist utopia. Fell apart and.
Groups of people who were
basically like minded went off
and pioneered hamlet settlements on the
spur lines coming down into the valleys.
Very quickly.
There were 15 20 maybe 30 of these
little hamlets groups of 3 5 6
households. In the house.
That's the settlers were semi-autonomous
from the co-operative course all the land
belong to the co-operative there was no
survey title given to any individual
shareholder.
People started building homes
and it quickly became realised
that some sort of control was necessary.
One big a-frame was built
high up on a ridge.
Its roof obvious up and down the
entire length of the valley.
And rules were quickly passed that people
who wanted to build houses had to get.
Co-operative approval first.
A flag had to be raised to the
height of the intended roof
and otis given it a month later
approval could be sought.
And then the local council got in on the
act too and required building plans.
So the co-operative made it a condition
of granting the approval that.
Council approval bought plans be filed
with the secretary at the same time.
Some people built their own homes.
Normas for a riot of homes often just
small timber cabins with a single room
and of aranda. Sometimes.
Homes which approximated in size a
normal australian suburban home.
Sometimes quite rare. Unusual buildings.
A stone house or.
A fair i cement dome.
People pretty well left each other
alone. Those who are industrious.
Worked at building their
homes. Planting orchards.
Others quickly built a bit of
shelter and. Perhaps did nothing.
After that. Or perhaps focus that
energies on some aspect of music
or.
Environmental activism.
The cooperative meets at an annual general
meeting once a year and elects a board.
Under the rules of the cooperative the
board has ultimate power to make decisions
for
and binding upon the entire
community will shareholders.
For a long time the elected
board was more or less nominal.
It didn't exercise any independent power
because this invited accusations of being.
Some sort of fascist totalitarian.
The community instead.
Met every month at what was called a tribal
meeting and it was this and more for.
Yes meeting of never happened to turn
up once a month which tended to make
decisions and from time to
time implement them. Alive.
My observation would be
that. And still is that.
Most people are very loath to act as
policemen a lot of decisions have been made
over and over again reinventing the
wheel over the years not enforced
or implemented.
But perhaps gradually there's
building up a consciousness of.
What will be disciplined
and what will be tolerated.
Very liberty liberty liberal little else
liberal communities grown out of it.
Sin or most tolerance for differences.
Folk tend to leave each other alone
unless they absolutely transgress the
guidelines.
It's always sad and be that
there's been so little endeavour.
As regards growing orchards
and vegetable gardens.
There's still a lot of
weeds on the hillsides.
There's still a lot of dependence on
welfare. When one would have hoped.
Folk would be into.